laut nasa ist der titan anders als alle
anderen orte in unserem sonnensystem und
zudem vergleichbar mit der frühen erde
genau deswegen will die nasa im rahmen
der mission dragonfly schon im jahr 2026
eine hightech drohne zum größten
trabanten des saturn fliegen das
autonome fluggerät libelle soll dort
nach außerirdischem leben suchen warum
genau wird es kein rover sein der diesen
fernen ort erkundet und wie
erfolgversprechend ist diese
nasa-mission wirklich klicks um science
fiction die gibt's täglich
faszinierendes 1 videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
herzlich willkommen
der saturnmond titan ist in vielen
hinsichten tatsächlich der frühen erde
ähnlich auf ihm gibt es seen wolken
stürme und sogar kaarst landschaften
also eigenartige gelände formationen
auch weil der titan eine atmosphäre
besitzt vergleichen ihn experten und
expertinnen oft mit der frühen erde
doch auf dem saturnmond ist es außerdem
extrem kalt kein wunder schließlich ist
er zehn mal weiter von der sonne
entfernt als die erde so sind eisige
temperaturen von minus 180 grad celsius
keine seltenheit in seinen gewässern
befindet sich außerdem kein wasser
sondern flüssiges methan und methan
solche organischen moleküle gelten als
bausteine für das leben und so wird der
titan oft auch als aussichtsreicher
kandidat gehandelt auf dem sich
außerirdisches leben befinden könnte
genau deswegen hat es auch die nasa auf
diesen saturn mond abgesehen im jahr
2026 soll die missionen dragonfly
starten und schon acht jahre später im
jahr 2034 soll die hightech thronen
namens libelle den himmelskörper
erkunden dieses autonome fluggerät ist
und drei meter groß und verfügt über
vier doppel rotoren
dadurch wird sie mit einer
geschwindigkeit von 36 kilometern pro
stunde über die titan oberfläche sich
bewegen können insgesamt soll sie laut
plan
in der dreijährigen missions- zeit mehr
als 175 kilometer weit an verschiedene
orte fliegen und die landschaften des
titels und ihre chemie erkunden damit
würde drängen frei eine längere strecke
zurücklegen als alle bisherigen planeten
rover zusammen warum dazu thomas zu
buchen
von der nasa der titan ist anders als
alle anderen orte im sonnensystem und
dragon fly ist wie keine andere mission
wird eine welt besuchen die von einer
großen vielfalt an organischen molekülen
erfüllt ist sie sind die bausteine des
lebens und könnten uns den ursprung des
lebens selbst verraten und die drängen
frei sonde ist tatsächlich besonders
anders als beispielsweise auch der
geplante mars hubschrauber der in zwei
jahren ab 2021 den mars aus der luft
erkunden könnte die atmosphäre des
titels macht es möglich dass die gesamte
dragonfly sonder abheben kann
sie ist somit mehr als ein reiner
mitfahrer einer großen lande sonde
denn die acht rotoren bekommen durch die
titan atmosphäre die firma dichter ist
als die der erde reichlich auftrieb
angetrieben wird die drohne laut der
nasa pläne dabei von einem
thermoelektrischen radioisotopen auch
die energieversorgung der voyager sonden
läuft so ab hierbei zerfällt
beispielsweise plutonium 238 und die
entstehende hitze wird dann in
elektrischen strom umgewandelt so können
messungen durchgeführt und instrumente
beheizt werden und auch der funkkontakt
zur erde wird so gewährleistet an bord
hat die dragon fly reichlich unter
anderem verschiedene analysegeräte
spektrometer und sensoren damit wird sie
auf ihrer tour viele verschiedene
landschaften des titels ins visier nimmt
laut nasa steht nach der landung
zunächst das dünen feld von shangri-la
an dessen topographie ein wenig an die
dünnen rhein in namibia ihn an als
zweiter punkt ihrer erkundungstour wird
der welt einschlagskrater mit seinen 90
kilometern durchmesser eingeteilt ein
äußerst spannender stoff denn hier
könnte die nasa auf ihrer suche nach
leben fündig werden denn hier gibt es
nicht nur hinweise auf gefrorenes wasser
das hat man früher messungen nahe gelegt
und somit den tätern als potenziellen
lebensraum ins spiel gebracht zum
anderen gibt es in dieser gegend des
titels hinweise auf komplexe organische
moleküle rötlich braune torlinie nämlich
sie bestehen aus wasserstoff stickstoff
und kohlenstoff auch für die nasa selbst
ist die mission eine aufregende und
einmalige sache dazu nasa chef jim
prince seien noch vor wenigen jahren
wäre
diese innovative mission undenkbar
gewesen jetzt aber sind wir reif für den
flug der dragon fly die drohne die ganz
genau genommen ein quadrocopter mit
doppelten rotoren ist wurde in einem
labor in baltimore entwickelt die
ausgereifte technologie soll garantieren
dass die drohnen auch dann weiter
arbeiten kann wenn ein roter beschädigt
ist
an der entwicklung beteiligt war auch
der us-wissenschaftler rolf deml
er beschreibt den nasa plan so dragonfly
ist eine mutige wegweisende art das
sonnensystem zu erkunden diese mission
könnte uns helfen einige der
entscheidenden mysterien des weltalls zu
entschlüsseln
darunter unsere eigenen ursprüngen nicht
umsonst hatte der us raumfahrt ingenieur
robert zu bringen sogar schon einmal die
kolonisation des titels ins auge gefasst
gibt es leben auf dem titan tatsächlich
kann man dazu heute schon eine menge
sagen und das tut team von us comics tv
anklicken anschauen und ab so comics tv
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran